this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much I'm not sure I know
the guy that he was talking
it's a pleasure to be here and I thought
maybe the way to start this off would be
to give you a sense of my personal
journey I I got my masters and PhD in
astrophysics at a university called
University of Pennsylvania I recognized
them at cornell and i was i was working
in planetary science for a little more
than a decade in half and i decided to
make a switch to full time national
science education i I've always been
fond of both research and education i
remember when i was in high school I
worked as a menu ensis for the New York
State Department of vocational
rehabilitation working with very
physically disabled students who were
brilliant trying to take them to the
next level up and I felt that education
was just so vitally important to what it
meant to be me that when I had a chance
to after my PhD I had an opportunity to
work as a NASA I'm sorry national
resources council postdoc at goddard
space flight center or helped establish
a lab for astrophysics at the National
Air and Space Museum which is the most
visited Museum on the planet and I gave
up the NRC postdoc in my my thesis
advisor said nobody gives up an NRC
postdoc what are you doing but to be
able to do research at the Smithsonian
and also be able to tell kids about it
and teachers about it and families about
what it's like to be a researcher was
really really important to me because
research and education went hand-in-hand
and so maybe what I should really start
off by telling you a little bit about
the emotional experience behind what I
did as a researcher and I can tell you
that my friends and I at Goddard Space
Flight Center had to build a very
special machine called an infrared
heterodyne spectrometer this was my
graduate work at Goddard Space Flight
Center and we would take this machine
which would fill a nice-sized classroom
it was a big machine out into the middle
of the Pacific Basin and we would take
it to the top of Mauna Kea which is on
the big I'll
Hawaii we've taken up 14,000 feet almost
three miles into the sky hook it to some
of the most powerful telescopes on
planet Earth pointed to planets tens of
millions of miles away and we would
measure temperature and composition of
the atmosphere and the very special
laser system that I built which was my
baby allowed us to measure gentle
breezes on these planets so we were able
to build the model of the global
circulation the global winds of these
planets and so I was sort of like an
interplanetary weather guy and I could
talk hours about why you would want to
do that why you would want to look at
weather across the family of worlds as a
means of getting a better understanding
of what drives weather here on earth but
I really wanted to talk about the
emotional context of what it was like
I'm Monica in fact I have a slide of
this this is the summit of Mauna can you
see some of the most powerful telescopes
on earth this is the Keck one and two
telescopes this is the telescope that we
use back in the mid 1980s through the
early 1990s it's the NASA in for a
telescope facility and the the summit of
Mauna Kea is really interesting because
tonight let's see this is Subaru this is
the Japanese national telescope does
anybody know why it's called Subaru what
do you see on the back of a Subaru Kyle
it wasn't named after the car what do
you see on the back of a Subaru what's
the symbol stars in Japanese Subaru
means the Pleiades and so this is the
Japanese national telescope and you go
up to the summit of Mauna Kea and you go
up towards the afternoon right after
dinner which is your first meal of the
day and you work all night you come back
down and you go and have breakfast just
before you go to sleep and you have
breakfast with people working from all
over planet Earth I mean scientists from
from every corner of this planet and you
sit down over breakfast when you talk
about what you're researching and
somebody might be looking at planetary
atmospheres or somebody might be looking
for planets around other stars and how
the universe was born or how stars form
and it's just a remarkable experience
because
place knows note this place knows no
national boundaries it's about humanity
pushing the envelope and so a few years
back a teacher came to me at a
professional development she said what
does it feel like to work on the summit
of mauna kea what does it feel like to
do research up there and and so I
thought about that and I came up with
really three levels of emotion that you
feel on the summit on the first thing
that's really remarkable is that when
you go on to the summit of Mauna can the
puffy white cumulus clouds roll in they
roll in a mile below your feet so you're
like on a rock floating in the middle of
the sky and when the Sun sets and the
sunsets are absolutely spectacular
countless stars 10,000 stars fill the
heavens and if you've been to a dark
site here on the surface of the earth
and went oh wow looking up at the
heavens that's nothing compared to what
you see at 14,000 feet almost three
miles into the sky and so here you are
on the highest point on earth looking
out into the universe the Milky Way
galaxy are there is this double band of
light that just arches from heaven to
heaven 10,000 stars fill your sky and
the only word that I've ever come up
with that has some chance of describing
what you feel in that moment is Majesty
you are standing here looking out at
majesty and what's really remarkable
about that story is that you're not
looking at it from the outside your part
of it and it's part of you which means
that you are the universe contemplating
itself that's a remarkable statement but
it's absolutely true and the next level
of emotion that you feel is when you
shift your gaze down to the horizon you
see all of these these instruments of
exploration this this this set of
powerful telescopes that peer to the
edge of the known universe and you get
this overwhelming sense of history
that's standing on the shoulders of past
generations this is what we are doing
that you are
part of a legacy of human exploration
and the way that it works is quite
remarkable because every generation adds
to the body of knowledge every
generation grows frail and every
generation in that moment reaches down
to the children and says it's your turn
to take us where we've never been it's
it's your turn and be content in knowing
that all of the knowledge that was
passed to me by prior generations I give
to you and all of the knowledge that
I've acquired in my jet my generation in
my time I give to you take us where
we've never been before and and after
all of that sweat and toil this is the
state of human exploration pushing back
the envelope of human understanding in
terms of Earth's place in a greater
space the the third level of motion is
is really personal and I guess it
happened when I the laser system that I
built is really persnickety it's got a
detector that has to have a it has to be
kept cold at liquid nitrogen
temperatures the laser itself has
mirrors on actuators where the actuators
have to have a certain high voltage
feedback on them and so you're
constantly babying this thing and so in
the middle of the night some something
like three or four in the morning while
my friend is controlling this massive
telescope with a joystick we were
looking at Venus at the time and there's
this big image of Venus on the TV
monitor with a crosshair as to where
we're taking the data I'm sitting there
playing them on my laser getting it all
you know all back to normal and I
realized hey this is really cool look
what you're doing you're seeing the for
the first time the winds of Mars the
winds of Venus and you started out
little red train nursery school I
remember that moment I said I started
out and I when when kids gonna if I go
to a classroom and they say where do you
go to school I say well I started a
little richer a nursery school and they
kind of grimace because they they're
trying to figure out what university you
went to but the point is i started at
little retro nursery school and i
figured out those gifts that i had and
those things that i love and i worked at
them and I got to a point where I may
decisions along the way I got to the
point where i was on the frontier of
human exploration and every time i took
a personal step to places I've never
been I took the entire entire human race
with me that's what exploration is all
about and it doesn't matter if it's
science or art or poetry if you put
brush to canvas in a way nobody's ever
done before or prose to paper in a way
that nobody's ever done before or in
athletics you you do something that's
quite remarkable you're pushing the
envelope for the human race you're
taking us all where we've never been
before and what I realized was the power
of one that one person has the ability
to set their sights in a certain a
certain direction and take the race
where we've never been the power of one
and so those three levels of emotion
again are the sense that you're part of
this this universe is majesty and and
you have the ability to reveal how she
operates you've got this sense that
you're part of a lineage of human
explorers that we've been doing this for
countless generations and working
together we're doing remarkable things
and you get a sense that just one person
has the ability to do something quite
powerful and extraordinary I'm
describing science and I think that you
hear in my voice a level of emotion
which you know goes contrary to the way
you normally picture scientists right
look I don't wear a pocket protector I
don't have a white lab coat I know a lot
of my friends do you have white lab
coats but I don't associate with pocket
protectors I don't know that's not true
I just don't have one but the the point
though is that science is a very
emotional experience and in fact let me
broaden that to human exploration in
general because in a little while i'll
talk about science and i think the point
that i really need to make is that
science the scientific method which by
the way is taught badly often as a rigid
recipe for success as opposed to an art
form the scientific method is a misnomer
because science doesn't own it it's the
way we
learn it's the way we explore and that's
discipline independent so let me just
say and let me ask if you all have the
definitions down because I want to tell
you a little story very fast is the son
of star how many folks are science
majors I was going to say education well
education undergrads maybe sorta you
kind of run defense okay what who else
is here this is an audience
participation situation education grad
students anybody else science grad
students okay so good good mix so I have
to ask this question these questions
because it's a good mix is the sun.star
like the stars in the sky you sure okay
why does the Sun look so different why
does it look so big and bright because
it's really really really really close
right what's a galaxy if you're all
stars what do you call it when stars
like to hold together galaxy in our
galaxy is the Milky Way okay good so
here's the story you all live in ithaca
new york in a in an apartment or a dorm
or a house in the state of new york in
the united states of america on a
continent called north america on a
planet called Earth in a planetary
system called the solar system which is
the family of a tiny little dwarf star
we call the Sun in the local solar
neighborhood in the Orion spur of the
Milky Way galaxy a galaxy by the way
which has enough stars to give 50 stars
to every human being on earth and the
Milky Way galaxy is in the Local Group
of galaxies next to the Virgo cluster of
1,500 galaxies part of the Virgo
supercluster of fifty thousand galaxies
which makes up the tiny little sliver of
the universe that nature allows us to
see called the observable universe and
that is your address that's your address
and I by the way think it's high time
that
child on this planet is given the
opportunity to learn that address
because the human race needs quite a bit
of humility a good way to say it is we
all walk around like ships on the ocean
at the center of a horizon a personal
horizon and we have the hubris to say
that that's the center of the universe
let me say that again we all walk around
day to day just like ships on the ocean
at the center of a personal horizon we
could see out in all directions
uniformly and we have the hubris to
think that that's the center of the
universe it's the center of your
universe and I think it's important for
us to have a better understanding of
Earth in a greater space so let me let
me now just quickly did you like that
story so far okay let me just quickly
show that to you in photographs this is
this is the nature of our existence and
if you go above Earth's atmosphere you
get to see the the starry sky this and
one star looks big and bright that's the
Sun in the natural context the Sun is
just another star it only looks so big
and bright because it's really close and
it's a small star a million earths can
fit inside the Sun million earths can
fit inside the Sun does anybody know the
name of that star in the shoulder of
Orion Betelgeuse eight hundred million
suns fit in the star Betelgeuse 800
million if you put Betelgeuse where the
Sun is now we'd be inside it it would
swallow the orbits of Mercury Venus
Earth Mars and Jupiter pretty cool okay
here is a picture of the Earth from
space this this spaceship with all known
life aboard were water air and land
conspire to give rise to life whether
it's a bacterium that calls a drop of
water home or a blue whale that calls an
ocean a home this spaceship is teeming
with life and here is the photograph of
the comment of the United States and and
what you see is California's in daylight
and there's the Pacific nightfall sweeps
westward at about 700 miles an hour at
this latitude and then its wake we can
see our cell
the entire eastern seaboard lit up with
humanity that's us at night and here is
the photograph taken not too long ago a
few months ago by the Solar Dynamics
Observatory of the Sun burping and
that's the actual size of us and here's
a photograph taken by the messenger
spacecraft in January of 2008 as it
rounded the side of mercury the human
race had never seen and this craft came
from the earth it came from a tiny
little blue world which is right there
that's you from Mercury and here is a
photo image of what the voice via say it
differently in February of 1990 the
Voyager spacecraft was just beyond the
orbit of Pluto and a gentleman who you
may recognize Carl Sagan suggested that
the Voyager spacecraft turn its camera
platform back and image the solar system
from the outside or at least outside of
the planetary domain for the first time
in history he actually got pushed back
for that but he was successful and so
these are the photos that the reason
these are the orbits of the planets from
voyagers vantage point in February of
1990 here are the photos it was going to
take to look at Neptune and Uranus and
Saturn and Mars and an earth is in here
and here are the actual photographs and
there is Neptune and Uranus and Saturn
and Venus Mars was actually not in the
photo Jupiter and ladies and gentlemen
that's you Voyager is traveling at
40,000 miles an hour that's twice as
fast as the International Space Station
of the space shuttle it could orbit the
Earth it could go around the earth at
that speed in 45 minutes and at this
incredible speed to get to a nearby star
will take eighty thousand years eighty
thousand years and that's just two stars
Austin a nearby star there are enough
stars in the Milky Way galaxy to get 50
to every human being on planet earth and
we now know that the vast majority of
those stars have
silence of the sum of their own and so
this is you from from near Earth from
from near space and if you go out into
the Milky Way galaxy you see these
clouds of gas and dust from which stars
are born called nebulae and here are a
few Milky Way stars that get in the
photograph and this is known as the
Eagle Nebula and here is a picture up
close by the Hubble Space Telescope of
this region here and these little pink
things are solar systems that have just
been born we're seeing where we came
from this is an entire solar system
planets and star being born and what I'm
about to show you is a photograph in the
direction of Sagittarius of the closest
star to us Proxima Centauri it's in the
very center of the photo and if you take
a picture of Proxima Centauri a few
Milky Way stars get in the way and you
know this is like 50 stars and this is
like 50 stars and 50 stars and 50 stars
to how many blocks of 50 maybe 15 and 15
across 225 blocks of 50 stars this is
enough stars to give 225 people 50 of
their very own that's all this is
nothing this is less than nothing and
you see that star right there I think
somebody's looking back next time you
look up at the night sky think about
this I firmly believe somebody's looking
back and this is what we think we would
see if we left our home galaxy looking
in from the outside this is what 300
billion suns looks like from the edge
and if you look from above we'd see
something like this it's a spiral galaxy
where the spiral arms are the sites of
star formation and this is a really cool
photograph because there's a star
because I can see that the the spikes
over here the cross spikes and here's a
star and I'm losing sight of any others
maybe this one looks like a star over
here
or what are these these are galaxies
these are all galaxies every one of
these galaxies on average is enough
stars to give 50 to every person on
earth and you know how many galaxies we
think are in the observable universe
enough galaxies to give 50 galaxies to
every person on are you feeling small
yet and here is another photograph of
galaxies and and so has anybody ever
read horton hears a who by dr. Seuss my
favorite book by far I say murmured
hormad horton I've never heard tell of a
small speck of dust that is able to yell
so you know what I think why I think
that there must be someone on top of
that small speck of dust some sort of a
creature of very small size too small to
be seen by an elephant-sized we are the
whos in whoville and if you read that
book you know that the hoos were calling
out from a speck of dust and Horton was
listening with us with his incredible
hearing and he was having this
conversation with the who's in Whoville
the mayor of who-ville and he spent the
rest of the book trying to convince the
jungle creatures he wasn't a crazy
elephant we are the who's in Whoville
and we're calling out to the rest of the
universe not only with spacecraft but
ever since Marconi turned on the radio
in 1896 radio and then television have
been moving out at the speed of light
and thousands of stars are now bathed in
human signal we're calling out just like
the who's in Whoville and I think that
the real question that that you have to
ask in all of this how did how did we
reveal all this from this tiny little
world the story that I told you that I
started off by saying hey I'm on the
summit of Mauna Kea I'm looking at it to
majesty and then I tried to convince you
by telling you your address and walking
through those images yes it is a
majestic universe how did we reveal all
that let me say it a little differently
how did we reveal all that with
something the size of this
something the size of this gave rise to
that story where did it come from what
process did we use at what is
exploration what is human exploration
what are the fundamentals of how we
approach pulling back the veil of nature
on any facet of the universe and seeing
how she operates sort of a rhetorical
question not completely yes asking
questions observation anything else
discovery curiosity inquiry we're just
I'm just feeling words here okay listen
to all these words they're all very
powerful anything else all right let me
go on to the next next chapter why do we
go to school I'm now going to walk you
through my view of how we revealed the
majesty of the universe that story why
do we go to school why do you go to
school think about kindergarten
elementary school think about college
you're college career here at Cornell
why do you go to school I'm not going to
bite I swear I'm not going to bite
there's no wrong answer what to learn
how to learn I would argue you already
know how to learn it just takes a little
bit of coaxing anybody else why do you
go to school okay here let me let me
switch roles puff I know you're not
going to want to want to do this but
you're all parents what are we going to
do it during the day
what do your kid what do you expect your
kids to say in answer to a question why
do you go to school parents I'm sorry to
make the world a better place that's a
great answer I suspect there a lot of
parents that will not say that okay what
is that what is that ok attainable so
when I go to ya yes okay that's that's a
that's a profound statement because it's
so far reaching but let me tell you what
I hear when I asked elementary and
middle school kids that question ok and
and try to see whether or not that
extrapolates to your reason for being
here at Cornell kids will say I want to
go to school I need to go to school
because mommy and daddy say so that's
the first thing in here I need to go to
school because I have to get good grades
and get a good job because I have to
make money right and if you get the
higher grades well I need money because
I want a car and then you say well
you're going to eventually want a family
and you go on to have a mortgage oh
you're going to or or rent and you
you're going to have to put food on the
table and that's the reason we go to
school do you buy that that has
absolutely nothing to do in my mind with
why we go to school it's all wrong and
let me start off by saying something may
be profound when we explore we fulfill a
commitment of our own to our own
humanity
um I don't know you should ask your
parents this I don't I don't know if
you've ever had this conversation with
them but if I were to ask parents do you
remember that magical time when your
children were first starting to express
themselves with sentences and as a
parent I know what that magical time was
like I lived through it with my son
you've lived through it with your
daughter I lived through it with my
daughter that magical time when they're
first able to communicate with you and
express themselves and all parents will
remember that time and then you ask what
did your kids do when they first were
able to express themselves somebody said
it in one of the words before what y
which is a question kids will start
asking this unending stream of questions
so many questions so overwhelming are
the questions that adults tend to try to
squash it because they can't handle all
the questions so as soon as we're
capable of expressing ourselves we ask
lots and lots of questions and I had to
change the way i said this when my son
was born because I remember I was in a
family room with my son who well and
this was before he was able to to speak
he just knew a couple of words that's it
but he was an avid reader and the reason
I say that as we had this incredible
library of picture books do you remember
those big format picture books were like
every tree imaginable was on these pages
in the tree book and then there was the
car book in the truck book and I
remember this moment in time when we
were sitting on the family room couch
and I think it was i think it was of the
fish book and he i turned the page and
he pulled the page back and he looked at
me what da and i didn't know what he was
saying so i turned the page again and he
pulled the pat at the page back hard me
wen da da and then I again I didn't know
what he was saying so I turned the page
and he pulled the page back really hard
and he pointed to a particular
sure I can't remember what the fish was
let's let's say it was a tuna I don't
know and he said da da and I looked down
I said a tuna and he turned the page and
so what he was saying is daddy what is
this before I even had the ability to
express that to say what is this he was
asking questions were born to explore
we're born curious we've got to do it
because what it's what it means to be
human and we're also born with something
else so we're born curious we're born to
ask those questions were born
evidence-based learners what does that
mean well we are born to poke the
universe and see what happens we love to
poke the universe and see what happens
and a great example of a class of humans
that poke the universe really really
well our babies a baby will poke the
universe in every way it can and will
explore near versus far and up versus
down texture and color and sound a baby
will try to figure out how to bring that
glass of juice in a way so that the
surface remains horizontal until the the
child can get the glass to their mouth
and then drink it think about the
articulation in the fingers and the
wrist and the elbow and the shoulder to
make all that happen and the act of
poking the universe and seeing what
happens gives rise to two things first
of all it tells us how the universe
works and the second thing it does is it
tells us how to interact with the
universe we learn how to interact with
it because of the evidence it presents
to us so that's really really important
we are born curious and we are born
evidence-based learners so let me start
back with that first part limit limit
let me not say that give the answer away
not knowing something is a gift why
and how do you start that exploration
asking a question right not knowing
something is really a remarkable gift
because if you don't know something you
can ask a question and have a journey
that's what it's all about and I guess
the the only caveat is that you want to
know it by the time the examples around
so the act of journey the start of
journey is is brought about by asking a
question and so let me give you some
examples of the majesty and the question
there are common themes here I used the
word Majesty a few few times sparingly
there is Majesty in a question and I was
doing a professional development with
zoo staff at the National Zoo in
Washington DC and we were talking about
this and Roger Roscoe who was a curator
in the reptile house said Jeff I I know
what you're talking about because there
was one question that drove drove
everything I did as a kid when I wanted
to go out and explore and I said well
Roger what was that question he said I
wonder what's under that rock and so
this was the question that drove him I
wonder what's under that rock and he
would go and he would he would empower
himself as a learner to lift up a rock
and sea creatures that he never would
have seen if he didn't ask the question
this brave new world of creatures that
live under the rock and don't want to
come out in daylight and so with a smile
breaking across his face you know what
he did he said I wonder what's under
that rock and this rock in that rock and
after he's done he doesn't have done
that with all the rocks in his backyard
he moved over to the park I mean this is
what he told me and that that love of of
exploring the the world translated
professionally into he became a curator
at the reptile house at the National
Zoological Park and I said to Roger at
the time well that's really cool because
when I was in elementary school there
was a question like that that I used to
I wonder what's in that rock and I took
my dad's hammer and I would whack away
at rocks and it was like on the outside
they would be brown or gray and inside
hey this is really cool as courts in
here and I go to the museum and I would
see geodes do you have you ever seen gos
and it's like I would just whack rocks
all over the place and I had this this
rock collection which I probably still
have it somewhere in a box somewhere and
and I know I've told that story stories
to that story to a number of geologists
who said that's how I got involved in
geology whacking rocks open think about
another question and and some of the
most powerful questions are the most
elegant how far can I see so on a clear
day if you're out in an open field how
far can you see what do you think a few
miles yes you agree with that well wait
can you see the moon that's 240,000
miles away can you see the Sun that's 93
million miles away that star Betelgeuse
and the constellation of Orion which you
can see from any urban area because it's
so bright that's 500 light years away
one light year is six trillion miles
that's 500 times six trillion is three
thousand trillion miles and that's a
nearby star if you're in the southern
hemisphere you can see the large ins and
the large and small Magellanic Clouds to
name neighboring galaxies and if you
know where to look you can see the
center of the Andromeda galaxy the
nearest large galaxy to the Milky Way
and you're looking two million
light-years away that might started
traveling to us two million years ago
and is only getting to us now you can
see really far and so that one question
how far can I see provides this pathway
for a journey of discovery that's
stunning it's absolutely stunning so a
question is really really powerful and
here's something that I think ought to
be an appropriate reminder to any adult
okay next time a child comes at you with
question after question consider it a
gift because they chose you
you're helping the next generation of
explorer fulfill their commitment to
their own humanity people are taking
notes follow me on twitter you can see
many of these are short enough for 140
characters there's a reason for that how
do you answer a question well will that
give you an answer if you answer a
question with a question well ok how
would you answer sophisticated audience
a question you'd go to Google or Bing
right but wait a second is that how you
answer the question or is that
eavesdropping on in on somebody else's
answer to that question how do you
answer the question you poked the
universe you've got to find a creative
way to interact with the universe and in
the case of my field astronomy it's
really cool because light from all of
those things that we were talking about
before is streaming to the earth and the
earth gets in the way and that light
Falls without any importance on the
surface of the earth and its God but if
you poke the univer if you interact with
the universe by putting large light
buckets in front of the light streaming
in we call them telescopes and you
collect the light and you're smart
enough to understand the information
contained in the light you can find out
how far and how bright and how big and
whether the winds are circulating on the
atmosphere of a planet far far away so
how do you an answer answer a question
you've got to interact with the universe
now I think what I'm trying to say here
is that what we know standing on the
shoulders of past generations have has
come to us because we have found
creative ways to explore and what we're
doing when we're just children
is naturally exploring we're not we're
not learning how to learn we already
know how to learn babies know how to
learn what we really need is is is a
little guidance it's sort of like it's
the students classroom and the teacher
lights the way okay it's not the
teacher's classroom it never was never
met was never meant to be the teacher's
classroom it's the students classroom
and the teacher lights the way the idea
is that we know how to learn we know how
to poke the universe we know how to ask
questions we know how to frame a pathway
to an answer but sometimes you need to
hurt herd the cats a little bit to
provide the tools that will allow it to
be a very efficient exploration so what
is science because you know I've talked
about what what it's what it means to be
human in terms of exploration what is
science because formally science is what
revealed the majesty of the universe
what is science you asked scientists and
engineers what do you do what would they
say
way of knowing how is that different
than what we've just been talking about
in terms of human nature in terms of
exploration it's not I like that can we
use that on Twitter you know what
science is its organized curiosity it's
organized curiosity and you know what
sciences it's evidence based learning
for the entire human race it's evidence
based learning for the entire human race
science grows organically from what it
means to be human we're born curious
organize it you get science we're
evidence-based learners organize that
into a process by which you can can
really put evidence to the test you get
science think about it I'm a scientist I
go and I find out something new I'm
really excited about this new thing I
found I tell all of my colleagues
through scholarly publications and at
conferences I tell all my colleagues
about what I found they say I don't
believe you Jeff you know what I say
well you poke the universe the same way
and see what you find that's what
science is it's a torture test you you
you make your evidence you know you're
an evidence-based learner you've you
figured out what the evidence is you've
presented it in scholarly publications
and now you you invite the entire cific
scientific community to throw darts at
it and you know what happens sometimes
you find out you were wrong you know
what happens sometimes everybody finds
out the same thing and it's like the
whole world goes to all new plays so
science as I said is a natural outgrowth
of what it means to be human so the next
logical question in this story is what
should science education be
there's a pathway I'm getting to a point
here and let me go back to something I
said earlier which is that the process
by which we ask a question and the art
by which we frame a pathway through the
noise of the universe around us in quest
of an answer and the act of pulling back
the veil of nature and seeing something
wholly new and the joy that breaks over
your your you know breaks across your
face when you see something wholly new
is science where was I going with this
ah science education well that process
you know in an organized way you know is
is the scientific you know you well let
me say it a little differently that
process is the scientific method and
it's an art form it is not a rigid
recipe for do this do this do this do
this I can tell you that two scientists
approaching the same problem okay may go
at it completely different ways and one
scientist approaching two different
problems well they may go out at two
different ways because the problem
demands it and I can tell you there a
scientist that will not hypothesize to
begin with because they don't want to
bias the results lots of science is done
by poking it and just seeing what
happens so the scientific method I think
we do a very bad job in teaching in
classrooms but the more important thing
is that process of exploration and
learning that I described is that
science specific what about history if
you want to learn about the Civil War
okay instead of parroting facts and
information here memorize all of this
stuff okay or let's say Truman okay the
decision to drop the bomb okay instead
of a bunch of facts and figures to
memorize for the exam exam your Truman
and is Joint Chiefs of Staff and it's
cabinet that's who you are you're making
the decision to drop the bomb what is it
that you would need to consider in other
words you can put students in the moment
provide them a problem in history and
history becomes alive it becomes
something that is more organic and so I
think what I'm saying is
that process that I'm describing here is
the way humans like to learn it's the
way we're born to learn and it's
discipline independent and so therefore
my question becomes how then should
education be conducted so that it's
effective education you know what should
and I'll give the example of science
education what should science education
be what is it then what is the nature of
science education if it's going to be
effective and so let me um let me take
you through a couple of other things my
thoughts on education some some of my
thoughts on education education a
question we should be asking that don't
what is the role of Education you tell
me what's educational about what's the
point of education what's the point of
going to Cornell what is the set of
objectives that you're trying to mean
I'm not talking about you know
downstream the job the Diploma the
education what's the point I'll give you
a hint here's a here's a tweet I put out
that went viral student why do I have to
learn all this stuff system because we
want you to get a good job as a search
engine what is it what do I mean by that
did it do it I'm sorry you find that
else so it's important for you to know
all of the state capitals by the time
say you're ten because that information
is hard to come by how many of you in
your you know you've gone through a
through 12 education system how many of
you remember subjects where the
educational experience was memorizing
information how do you feel in the age
of Google you know it's like 10 minutes
okay I saw that that's good that's good
you never throw anything okay um you
know what's interesting is I used to
tell students years ago I go into a
classroom and they wanted me to talk
about careers and you know how I made my
decisions and what I
did and I used to say something that I
now kind of sort of regret I used to say
to students you know knowledge is power
the more you know the more capable you
are to decide what you want to do with
your life so school is really really
important you got to know you know as
much as you can that's really not right
that's not correct what what happens if
all of a sudden somebody finds this the
Amongus the positive gold what will
happen to the value of gold it'll
plummet because there's a lot of it well
look at Google look at the information
age look at look at the knowledge base
of the human race online and you know in
the not-too-distant future I'm sure a
couple of generations from now you're
going to be able to plug your brain into
the human knowledge base and what then
of education knowledge and let me say
this for effect I don't believe it to
the depth of what I'm about to say but
i'll say it for effect just to make the
point knowledge is virtually useless
it's everywhere you know we were we were
driving in the car and we were talking
about William Penn in Philadelphia and
we were having this debate while William
Penn must be like you know five ten
stories high and I pulled out my iphone
5 and it's like five hundred and forty
seven feet high William Penn is fifty
four stories up in Philadelphia it's
like incredible it's I have the power at
my fingertips to probe the the knowledge
base of the human race and so the power
doesn't lie in how much you know the
power lies in your ability to do
something with the knowledge what's
power is your ability to use the
knowledge to do something with the
knowledge and actually that's true in in
virtually every field a bold statement
when it comes to education we must stop
telling our children that knowledge is
power we just talked about that and and
so it's not about the information
knowledge education is not should not be
about the information
and over here education must not be
about dictating to our children what
they should be curious about you know
what's really reprehensible forcing a
child to sit in a classroom for six
hours and telling them what they should
be curious about that denies them I
think I said it on the next slide here
it is okay education that denies our
children their curiosity and their need
to poke the universe is not education
worthy of our children it's the it's the
students classroom not the teachers the
teacher lights the way and if we take
away ownership and learning from the
child what we are doing is denying them
their need to be explorers and there are
ways the ways to do this what I'm asking
what I'm what I'm suggesting here is not
difficult to do so going back to what is
innately human the journey is written in
our genes the book of knowledge is not
what should that tell us about the role
of Education okay let's go buy it go
back to biology the journey is written
in our genes do we have to teach our
children those chilies for instance how
to explore their universe the journey
the process of inquiry and exploration
is written into our genes the book of
knowledge is not so what should that
tell you about education how education
should proceed shouldn't it be nurturing
what is already in us shouldn't it be
about nurturing the gift of a question
and an inquiry-based exploration should
it be about recognizing that there is
core knowledge to let me say it this way
when you ask a question if you
understand how to play the game the art
of learning you recognize that there is
core knowledge that you need to bring to
the problem at hand and there is core
knowledge that we ought to be teaching
our children basic conceptual
underpinnings across the board
and then you find a pathway to address
that question and the answer is the
creation of new knowledge the objective
ought to be the student's ability to go
through that process and create new
knowledge at least new knowledge to them
so education that the title of the talk
was a teacher's gift nurturing education
and our children what education ought to
be about is that nurturing of
exploration in our children nurturing
exploration in our children now let me
give you some some examples okay and
maybe this is on the next slide what do
I want to say let's go to the next slide
in a long day ready okay okay well I
didn't get to the other slide but yeah
education needs to be about journey it
needs to be about process and what are
the skills required ownership and
learning critical thinking
problem-solving navigation of an
interdisciplinary landscape teamwork
ownership and learning is so important
it's like you know here's an example for
you know elementary school generalists
you know it's like are you telling me
that you want me to to allow unfettered
exploration of my my science class
letting all of this the students go and
do whatever they want and I understand
that problem and I can tell you that
when I was building the the carbon
monoxide carbon dioxide laser system for
the heterodyne spectrometer no divine
hand gave me the procedures on how to
build it nor would I have taken it as
soon as the science teacher say gives
procedures for an experiment to their
class they're ensuring that no science
is going to be done that day why because
who owns the procedures the teacher
you've taken all of the ownership away
from the students you're asking them to
be technicians follow these procedures
but a creative compromise is for you to
with the class explore the
problem at hand so your class comes up
with the experiment you happen to have
written up do you hear what I just said
okay a good teacher an artful teacher
will be able to to facilitate
conversation in the class so that the
class moves in some direction and if you
can get your students to come up with
the experiment you happen to have
written up why is that a difference
between night and day who owns it then
they do and that's really really
important so ownership and learning is
important critical thinking
understanding logic you know I think
that there should be a bar that has to
be passed for people who want to go into
public office they have to pass a
critical thinking test you know i I just
I don't understand i was saying this to
a couple of people akin you know the
famous the the famous congressman who
said that in case of in case of
legitimate rape a woman has the ability
to shut down a pregnancy and Braun from
Georgia who said that um evolution and
the Big Bang are the biggest lies of the
devil and and and here's the insanity
both of these gentlemen sit on the US
House Science Space and Technology
Committee okay so you know we have a
problem ladies and gentlemen okay
problem solving that aren't formed by
which you take a question and find a
pathway to an answer navigation of an
interdisciplinary landscape you know how
many of you took you know trigonometry
and calculus remember that okay do you
know how many students that take
trigonometry and calculus ask this
question why do I need to know this
stuff because because the math is taught
in full I salacious from actual use math
is the language of nature if you want to
understand hurry and understand how she
operates you have to speak her language
it's a language and if i were to teach
French and and you are never going to
use that French to talk to other people
who speak French or go and read the
literature that and newspapers in French
and understand the French culture
if you were never to do that why would
you want to take French just to memorize
vocabulary why would we subject our
students to the stovepipe math courses
with no connection to why math provides
the ability for the human race to see so
interdisciplinary landscapes you've got
to navigate it's not like opening a
physics book in closing and opening a
chemistry book and closing it an opening
in art Burke book life is an
interdisciplinary tapestry and education
ought to mirror that maybe I'm asking
too much for the education system but
what I'm simply saying is that education
ought to be nurturing what is natural to
human learning so and as an example as a
working example that I'm familiar with
in terms of science education which is
now called stem okay if you if you've
been doing good science education it had
to be stem because science technology
engineering and math cannot be done in
isolation from from each other but my
view is if if exploration is something
that our children are born to be able to
do and science is nothing but organized
curiosity and evidence based learning
for the human race our children are
capable right now of being immersed in
real science and doing science which
means that science education could be
about modeling real science immersing
kids in science letting them be
scientists and engineers right now not
talking about the science knowledge base
the book of knowledge is not science
that's what you get from science or
talking at science let them do science
and the program that we did to really
put that to the test which has been very
successful as the student space flight
experiments program where we can say to
a school district we're going to give
you your own space program we're going
to give you a real microgravity mini
laboratory and all launch services to
get it to the International Space
Station have an astronaut assigned as a
technician to operate the single
experiment that contains return it
safely
earth and just like NASA that school
district at the local level says to at
least 300 students you're all scientists
and break into research teams on each
team design your own microgravity
research program and each team does
write your own research proposal which
will go through a formal two-step
proposal review process just like
professional researchers and one of
those teams will have their experiments
selected for flight and we're doing this
with 5th graders grades 5 through 12 and
it is stunning what we're seeing we've
had 20 1,700 students fully immersed in
experiment design and proposal writing
over 4,000 proposes all this since 2010
students are saying I never knew this
was science teachers are saying wow this
is a completely different way to teach
science a project based approach
immersing students in every facet of
real research and they even get their
own research conference at the
Smithsonian's National Air and Space
Museum so I have obviously all we're out
of time I gotta stop we obviously have
some very strong opinions about human
exploration science and science
education and more generally human
exploration and you know professional
exploration and how we teach in an
interdisciplinary way subjects in the
classroom but i also have a track record
for putting that into practice and i
think that what we are in right now as a
as a test based educational system that
stifles creativity that denies many
learners the ability to be curious that
forces testing education to serve
testing and not testing serve education
is a recipe for success is not a is
arrested is it's a recipe for success
for China well I pulled that out at the
last minute okay so i think i'll stop
here i'm certainly able to answer any
questions if people want to mill around
or
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu